منذ نحو شهر عندما بدات اخر فصول ازمات
شيرين مع حسام اخر ما كان يتوقعه جمهور
شيرين ان يصلهم اشعار الى هواتفهم يعلن
عوده النجمه الى طليقها حسام بعد نحو عام
تقريبا من اعلان الانفصال عام تخلله
الكثير جدا من الازمات اهمها ربما ايداع
شيرين مصحه للعلاج من الادمان شيرين تخرج
وتعلن ببساطه في مكالمه هاتفيه عدت لحسام
حبيب اشكرك جمهوري واعدكم الا اخذ لكم
ابدا
جمهور شيرين يشعر بالظهور والدعم الذي
استمر طوال الاسابيع الماضيه تحول الى غضب
وطالب البعض حتى بمقاطعه الفنانه ومع ان
اختيار الانسان لشركه امره الشخصيه لكن
محبي شيرين يقولون كما يقول المثل الشعبي
العتب على قدر المحبه
اعوذ بكلمات الله التامات من شر ما خلق
يعني امان للبيوت ونسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان يجمع بينكما في الخير والسعاده
انه قريب ذلك مولاه والقادر عليه
من المستشفى من طلب منك ذلك تحديث
اللي هو طريق الفنانه
توجهت للمستشفى في اليوم دوت لان كان في
محاولات قبليها في النيابه وفي المستشفى
نفسها من الاستاذ ياسر الدوسري اللي هو
محامي الفنانه
[موسيقى]
لان طبعا كان في اخطاء كثير في دخولها
وعدم خروجها وبقاء في المستشفى المده دي
كلها يعني طيب استاذ مصطفى ما الذي دفع
عقلي قبول هذه الخطوه خصوصا انه الكل يعرف
انه لشرين عندها محامي هو الاستاذ ياسر
انطوش
سعادتك
كان في محاوله سابقه في نفس اليوم يعني
وطبعا بقت بالفشل
فلما انا طبعا درست الكلام اللي هم قاله
لي والمده اللي هي كانت موجوده فيها
الفنانه
فطبعا حضرتك احنا عندنا قانون اللي هو 71
لسنه 2009 ده اللي بينظم دخول المريض
المستشفى سواء اراضي او الزامي فطبعا
المده ما بتقعدش الكلام ده كله مش موجود
في القانون لان لها مده فتره زمنيه
وبيتبلغ المجلس الاقليمي للسياحه النفسيه
عشان خاطر بقاءها او عدم بقاءها في
المستشفى فانا كنت شايف من دراسه الموقف
كله ان في مخالفه واضحه المستشفى وتعنت
ليه طبعا عشان كده انا دخلته والحمد لله
ربنا يوفقني وهمم وخرجناها والمفروض ان
احنا كنا هنروح ناخذها ثاني يوم بس همم
طبعا الزملاء الاستاذ ياسر الاستاذ حسام
حبيب راح اخذوها قبل ميعادنا مثلا بساعتين
ثلاثه
ما السبب الذي يجعل شيرين تعود لحسام
مع الاستاذ
ان هي خرجت مع الاستاذ قلت له والله انا
اشك في الكلام ده لان اللي انا شفته
والاستعانه بي طبعا هو الاستاذ حسام حبيب
واستاذ حسام الشيخ كان هو اللي موجود في
يعني قبل تبعا تواجد بايام وموجود في
النيابه في نفس اليوم عشان يقول بقى قال
عشان يخرجها وهو اكثر واحد كان صاحب
المصلحه
واكيد هم كانوا على تواصل بكده وهو طبعا
يعني اكيد كان منتظرها عشان الخطوه اللي
هم عملوها دي يعني كل الموضوع ده كان مرتب
وهمم واضح وكان موجود بس طبعا هو ما كانش
ظاهر على الساحه عشان كان السوشيال ميديا
والاعلام كان عامل دقه في الموضوع ده
[موسيقى]